splitscreen maybe a dying breed but that
doesn't mean it's extinct Gears of War 4
boss Rod Fergusson appeared on the game
informer show to talk about Microsoft's
latest third-person shooter during the
interview Ferguson confirmed
split-screen discuss the upcoming beta
and then an explicit language and gore
filter will be in the game couch co-op
is nothing new to this series since the
original players have been able to play
through the campaign and other modes
like horde mode in split-screen Ferguson
told game informer anyway you can play
Gears of War you can play split-screen
unfortunately the game's framerate will
drop to 30 frames a second when you do
so it was previously announced that the
campaign is expected to run at 1080p and
30 frames a second while the multiplayer
is shooting for around 60 frames a
second if that's the case the frame rate
should only affect the multiplayer the
Gears of War 4 developer also discussed
the upcoming beta Ferguson stress that
the beta will be a technical beta that
is nowhere near ready for launch he went
on to say that some betas today are like
marketing vessels in referring to Gears
of War 4 he said quote honest to god
it's a technical beta Gears of War 4
will also have a Gore and explicit
language filter will be bleeped out but
you will still hear shaken god damage
generally what we tend to do is take out
the hardest of the hard because we don't
want to over bleep a fire game I tend to
look at radio and go a little bit
further than that so generally anything
around the word tends to stay turned off
you can also turn the gore off if you
bike years of war 4 follows the story of
Marcus Fenix a son and two other
characters the game will take place over
the span of 24 hours and the beta will
begin on April 18th if you want to get
in on it you'll need to play Gears of
War Ultimate Edition before the 11th